there's a lot of grit out there right
now here in the second half steph curry
drives leia backs it in and a foul
grown man moved by curry
[Applause]
well curry with just ten points just 4
14 from the field he does have six
assists
wiggins curry thompson porter and looney
for golden state curry step back three
it's good steph curry
puts the warriors back up by three
shooting slump that means i was in a
shooting slump for 17 years
it's ridiculous how great this guy is
brooklyn hasn't taken a lot of threes in
the second half but they're six for
seven
thompson a corner three got it
one point game with 220 to play
tops it on the drive the pull-up punch
it in
back to thompson thompson three-pointer
thompson from denham town
the lead is up the floor timeout
brooklyn
[Applause]
[Music]
put your two best players in the action
clay thompson slips this high screen
give steph curry credit the patience to
get rid of the basketball and trust his
dynamic dance partner
you